I started studying English so I started
back from scratch you know I hadn't went
and they paid for a tutor and I went
from like English 101. and then I went
through that in a couple of months then
and then I got another guy with whom we
I expanded this we had conversations
rather than working from a textbook and
I and I worked like a maniac I threw
myself into the study of of uh uh
English like it wouldn't believe
um and and my inspiration came from
Vladimir Lenin I had read somewhere in a
book that when Lenin was in Exile
he studied German
and he learned 100 German words every
day no German words so I started reading
newspapers and every word that I didn't
know I wrote down and on an index card
uh German English and I piled him up
and so I really learned 100 new English
words
every day I know this because I counted
them and I had a system how to do this
so you take your index card and you have
five categories there's a really good
way to learn wrote by wrote
so you got category one that's the new
ones and you got category five five so
you start with uh with five five you
already had right four times if you have
it right again it goes upgraded it go
out into the archive
oh and like long-term cold archive yeah
four if you get it right it goes to five
if you get it wrong it gets relegated to
three
oh so and so you go through this
and uh um
and occasionally I would throw the
archived things back into one
so I really I really acquired a
phenomenal of a vocabulary when I was
done with my English my vocabulary was
significantly higher than the average
American because I I didn't discriminate
whatever word I didn't know I learned
which is not necessarily the best way
because
you know English has a lot of synonyms
right yeah and uh and one synonym is
usually the preferable one and and I uh
when I first interacted with people I
very often used the one that wasn't as
good
and people have found that I you know I
have an interesting way of talking they
didn't know what that meant but yeah
well so it builds a good foundation for
a language it's getting a large
vocabulary yes it's a really interesting
there's something I do which is called
space repetition which is a programmatic
way of doing this kind of system that
you've developed yourself which is if
you successfully remember a thing it's
going to be a longer time before it
brings it up to you again yeah now
that's requires a computer
to keep track of my information if you
have cars that's a really interesting
pile system one two three four five you
upgrade it one two three four five maybe
I wouldn't go to the archive and go to
num to to pile one right away maybe I
would go to like I don't know pile
five perhaps is probably the right place
to put it because because you have to go
through that full step again but that is
a really powerful way to uh learn
definitely language but also facts like
people that go to medical school
disconnected facts yeah uh and and you
pretty much when you're done you you
know what you know yeah you don't have
then again to use it to integrate it
into the music of language that's more
difficult that's what you talk exactly
right exactly there's a charm
I mean maybe it's not good for spycraft
but there's a charm to this kind of to
having an accent
and using words incorrectly but
confidently there's a because language
isn't a simple formula language is the
play of words so actually using the
incorrect synonym
you know as it uh
you know if instead of saying I'm cold
saying I'm chilled yeah something like
using off beat words can actually be
part of the charm so it's interesting if
you can learn how to use that correctly
um because I've known a bunch of people
with the Russian accent and I feel like
they get get away with saying a lot of
ridiculous [ __ ] because they're able to
sort of Leverage the charm of the uh
non-sequiturs and by the way by the way
just one one thing um though you talked
about using a computer when I had my
first personal computer I actually wrote
a program that does that